in the second part of our exclusive
conversation with four people lost loved
ones to mass shootings we talked about
the role of forgiveness and being part
of a group linked together by a tragedy
it's a club nobody wants to join we
first heard from Stephanie Melendez
after her father was killed at the
shooting in El Paso Texas just three
weeks ago she told CBS News evening
anchor Noor O'Donnell he died protecting
her daughter and her mother on our panel
Stephanie Melendez and others talked
about the after-effects of sudden loss
your life is is ordinary and and
everything is in place and then in a
moment your world changes
I live in El Paso which has been named
one of the safest cities all I know is
that my dad went and took my daughter
shopping for clothes and the next minute
he was gone you feel like you're in a
state of shock I think it would be
called shark mm-hmm in the beginning it
was a fog and you couldn't see clear but
you've learned to navigate day by day
one day might be a good day another day
I don't want to get out the bed and
still yes still there were years later I
can't call my mom's and ask her how do
you cook gumbo to go to Charleston now
is very difficult for me
she mentioned like picking up the phone
there's times I still pick up my phone
right I called my dad and I can't it is
not fair to create this permanent
underclass of of people who have to do
this in addition to didn't you say you
have to go back to work next week are
you thinking Stephanie I have to get
back to living my life for my daughter
for my kids you know she's been through
so much she was there she was there and
I need to show her that the world
doesn't stop what would you all say to
that she's saying I have to make life
normal again I have to get back to work
I would advise sucks that's the first
thing I'm going to say advice sucks and
I'm answering because Gail asked me be
gentle with yourself and honor the every
day but I do think there's the
encouragement of El Paso strong Dayton
strong well how do you feel about that I
mean I know it's support but it's like a
reminder
this happened it's a reminder every day
yeah in the beginning it felt somewhat
comforting oh they haven't forgotten but
I think eventually people do move on and
the bumper stickers fade it is really
really wonderful to cheer El Paso strong
or Sandy Hook strong but it is even more
helpful to us if that came with a
commitment to lift us up forever because
we're not just grieving year one I will
grieve onna
until the day I die
were you all on the issue of forgiveness
for the shooter my sister was the first
one to say I forgive you on the TV and I
started screaming and hollering like 48
hours and you're talking about
forgiveness
they took me almost a year even being a
reverend so you have you have forgiven I
have now why in order to get all of that
anger and rage I had to get to a point
in understanding what I really believed
in my fate and to be able to be free
where are you Richard do you think
you're capable of forgiving him no no no
but were you on forgiveness I just don't
understand why it's a narrative we
quickly go to after shootings I'm glad
you're asking the question because now
other people can learn I saw it in
Newtown all of a sudden the forgiveness
families were in one bucket and those
were the the wise families and then the
ones who were like no why should I have
to forgive them we're seen as another
and they were asking that of Sandy Hook
families 24 hours later 48 hours later
and I'm like wait when did this become
my responsibility to absolve the person
who and to absolve it because I feel
like it's another way to let folks off
the hook I listen to a woman talking
about her experience in Las Vegas I'm a
veteran I served during the Vietnam era
and when this woman was talking to me
about the experience of what it was like
to be there at that concert Las Vegas it
reminded me of simulated combat
we were given the option of visiting the
classroom and one of the questions I
asked was where's the toilet and the
answer to that was we removed anything
that had been destroyed by gun violence
so if an industrial toilet was destroyed
by the firepower because you're thinking
imagine what it did to the children we
cannot as a nation say that is okay
because I didn't sign a six-year-old up
for war I signed her up for first grade
this is not our kids died because we
were negligent we have to address the
injustice that we are visiting on
American families it's like a hell's
lottery where if you lose today you lose
today and that's not okay it's a health
lottery Nobel says that we're all
playing you know and it could affect any
of us any of us in this room anybody was
listening to this at any time and one of
the reasons why we wanted to do this
story is because I feel that we're
becoming desensitized Steve Hartman who
does beautiful pieces for us here at CBS
I've seen many stories and after one
shooting he said we more and pray repeat
more and pray repeat and I've never
forgotten those words and I just want us
to see that behind all of these stories
as we all know there are people living
lives and people's lives were grossly
affected for the rest of their lives
woven into their family stories and I
can't I really want to hear it you can't
unhear it and I can't stop thinking
about it